quand nous sommes charlie je suis
charlie mais le sommes nous encore
écouter ce qu'en pense le directeur de
la rédaction actuelle de charlie hebdo
rice il était ce matin sur france info
et sans constat est un peu amer parfois
on rencontre des gens qui sont là
toujours prêts à nous soutenir
donc il ya quelque chose qui n'a pas
disparu mais aussi l'inversé des gens
qui eux ne se gênent pas pour nous dire
que toujours un peu comme on l'a entendu
même après le genre j'en ai 17 janvier
qu'on l'avait bien cherché et puis voilà
qui veut que il faut qu'on arrête de
faire la provocation voilà donc il ya
toujours des gens ce qu'ils sont aussi
là pour nous faire un peu la morale quoi
amuser à manier on est toujours charlie
où on a un peu baissé la garde
mais il a totalement raison dès le 8
janvier j'allais dire même dès le 7
janvier au sol y avait beaucoup de gens
qui n'étaient pas charlie c'est venu
très très vite et ce qui est vraiment
dramatique parce que c'était déjà avant
même les attentats moi c'est quelque
chose alors moi j'ai un rapport
particulier c'est que nous on est venu
ma famille s'est réfugiée en france
après la révolution islamique et au
moment du set depuis l'iran donc au
moment du 7 janvier ce qu'on a ressenti
nous avec nos parents c'est que les
islamistes vous avez couru après parce
que c'était les mêmes c'est une longue
histoire ce qui s'est passé à charlie
hebdo qui je pourrais vraiment alors là
vraiment faire de l'histoire on va pas
mais qui pourraient commencer au xième
siècle au moment où l'empiré musulman a
décidé de fermer ses quatre écoles
juridiques et ça commence à être
effectivement la dégénérescence de
l'espace arabo-musulman et ensuite
l'arrivée des frères musulmans en 1925
avec hassan al banna essayait de coude
qui ont pensé l'islam comme une
politique que khomeiny en tant que
chiites a piqué aux sunnites et a fait
la révolution islamique
là on parle de d'islamistes on parle de
politique en parle d'une doctrine
politique
ce qui est dramatique et ce qui ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui ce qui s'est passé
juste après charlie est juste avant
c'est qu'une partie
les islamistes ont réussi à convaincre
une partie de la gauche que les
islamistes étaient des musulmans et des
en plus par une toute l'extrême droite
et une partie de la droite dure et qu'
ils ont réussi à maintenir cette
confusion entre islamistes et musulmans
qu'on est en train de payer concrètement
aujourd'hui c'est que charlie est devenu
dans la tête de beaucoup de gens qui
sont pas forcément des terroristes en
puissance prêt à tout
un journal satirique anti musulmans
alors qu'on avait fait le calcul il y
avait eu quatre fois plus de couverture
anti vatican anti-pape sur les avoirs de
pédophilie ou autre que concernant
l'islam donc ce qui est très grave c'est
c'est là on peut dire que les islamistes
ont gagné parce que cette confusion et
l'ont maintenu qu'ils ont été pas aidé
par une partie de la classe politique
française etc c'est dramatique mais il
n'empêche oui d'une part il faut
continuer à être charlie et pour une
chose bête et méchante qui est la
liberté d'expression et c'est une grande
bêtise de dire qu'on ne peut rien dire
aujourd'hui parce qu on n'exerce pas la
liberté d'expression elles existent donc
disons ce qu'on a à dire c'est vrai qu'à
une peur une tension qui s'est installée
et ensuite parce qu'il ya encore
aujourd'hui des caricaturistes qui
meurent partout dans le monde en
l'occurrence mans de la révolution
islamique d'iran
mes parents ont perdu énormément d'amis
et en priorité ceux qui ont et tuer tuer
c'était les dessinateurs caricaturistes
et cinq sens donc on parlait tout à
l'heure de retrouver la démocratie le
sens de la démocratie le sens de la
république et bat être charlie ça fait
aussi partie de cette démarche-là a
continué à entretenir la république qui
me permets moi aujourd'hui des traces et
table à côté vous et passe sous le voile
ou déjà égorgé en iran ce qui est quand
même déjà pas mal
patrick lui joué très ému en regardant
ces images basque on se souvient que
vous avez été l'un des premiers à
arriver sur place après l'attentât vous
étiez chroniqueur à charlie
on se souvient de ces images très très
émouvante où vous êtes en larmes dans
les bras de françois hollande et 11
janvier alors question toute simple est
ce que la france est toujours charlie
aujourd'hui
oui oui elle est toujours oui elle est
toujours elle est toujours je suis
charlie parce que parce que c'est un
pays qui pour le veuille ou non qui
peut-être bouge pas suffisamment on
retombe sur les gilet jaune par exemple
sur ces valeurs
la france est un pays de valeur c'est un
pays l'histoire nous avons été de
grandes choses sur des conquêtes
notamment des droits de l'homme sûr et
puis là actuellement on est dans des
incertitudes c'est pour ça qu'il ya
souvent les doutes qui aurait cru que
ces attentats on voit les images du 11
janvier mais très près d'eux parce qu'il
ya eu six millions de personnes dans
paris mais vous avez eu des millions de
personnes autour des mairies en france
parce que là encore les mairies ont joué
un rôle important et donc je pense qu'on
est toujours parce qu'il ya ces valeurs
que comme tu viens de dire
il ya les valeurs aussi de nous sommes
le pays de rabelais nous sommes le pays
de molière on est un pays qui qui a
inventé des choses et nous avons un
vilain vente et l'impertinence
bon bah qu'est ce qui reste actuellement
il reste bien entendu
charlie hebdo il reste in et mensuels il
reste le canard enchaîné quelques autres
journaux hebdomadaires de caricatures et
donc c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
défendre parce que c'est la liberté
d'expression c'est la liberté
d'expression du figaro de marianne cci
liberté là et en effet je suis
complètement d'accord ce mois-ci mon
combat l'unique actuellement c'est ce
combat sur la défense de la laïcité la
défense du droit à blasphémer devoir
d'informer et de rire de tout c'est ça
qu'on doit défendre
or vous avez mieux merci de dire ça il y
à un islamisme politique qui vérole tous
actuellement est en effet c'est une très
bonne analyse de dire ça ils ont fait
croire à une façon de penser de penser
d'une partie de la gauche et aussi de la
droite que si on critiquer l'islam
on était islamophobe termes absolument
rédhibitoire et donc par conséquent on
était raciste ce qui est totalement faux
nous ne sommes pas racistes je ne suis
pas raciste mais je suis
extrêmement critiques contre cet islam
et cet islam politique qui essayent de
s'implanter véritablement en france dans
les institutions qui fait passer des
idées qui fait passer le fait que
finalement dans des banlieues le voile
est quasiment rendu obligatoire pour pas
que les femmes et les petites filles
perdues alors que c'est absolument pas
marqué pendant dans le corps
ça faisait mal mais on va vers une
exagération et où vous avez quand même
des aux dernières élections pour
l'assemblée nationale législatives vous
avez eu des candidats de l'islam
politique et on le banner anda les
écossais ont le banalise et c'est ça le
véritable danger et c'est là où on a
besoin en effet de savoir qu'on est
encore charlie périco légasse l'esprit
charlet a changé oui il est demeuré
intact
alors ceux qui ont pris conscience de la
gravité de cette chose pour moi c'est ce
qui s'est passé de plus graves depuis la
guerre dans l'histoire de france
7 c'est encore une fracture mais là
c'est une c'est une souffrance qui
mettait en cause notre identité
nationale républicaine l'âme de la
france ben yahia le 7 janvier il y avait
aux haras taur à toulouse qui est
absolument qu'ils auraient dû aussi
amené quatre millions 10 millions de
français dans les rues mais comme
c'était une synagogue et une école juive
ça n'a pas eu lieu parce qu'on
considérait que c'était un secteur de la
société 7 janvier ça mais encore
c'étaient des journalistes et des flics
donc ils avaient un peu cherché alors le
cas en novembre la ccir là et puis
maintenant j'en ont attaqué alors moi ce
qui est là je pense que nous avons
touché le fond de l'abomination du
comportement de certaines sociétés
françaises par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé ce jour là
cette gauche intellectuelle moraliste et
humaniste qui a commencé à jeter le
doute sur eux mais oui et je parle à des
gens très connus qui ont encore des
moustaches et qui sont devant les médias
dire attention c'est pas si simple quand
même il l'avait un peu cherché voilà les
i c'est mediapart qui est en plus ils 50
vraiment des valeurs on les aurait que
immédiatement arquebouté dans la défense
de ce que le char l'isthme parce que
charles ives 10 pouvait représenter
parce qu'ils en sont aussi et non on
essaie d'expliquer quand même que
et bien tout ça n'est pas innocent et
n'est pas étranger à une contre valeur
donner des explications
c'est abominable effectivement ça a jeté
le doute et ensuite on a dit mais n'en
voyez on veut jeter l'anathème sur
l'islam l'islam bon il s'avère pour
l'instant les gens qui tuent ils
viennent alors reste que ce sont des
dissidents est ce que ce sont des amis
brigitte il était bien radical musicale
et enchanteresse qui va sur les média
produit les sourates qui sont des
sources officielles qui ont pas été
démenti donc je vais dire quelque part
les islamistes sont des queues de son
les musulmans tout à fait marginale pas
si vous permettez je je je fais
intervenants les internautes parce que
vous savez que c'est l'un des principes
de cette émission c'est d'être
interactif d'abord via twitter où on
vous pose la question etes-vous toujours
charlie vous êtes 68% à nous répondre
oui et puis de réactions politiques ne
nous dit plus que jamais la france et
charlie elle le sera toujours temps dit
monsieur babineau nous dit l'esprit
charlie est bien faible
s'il existe encore en france mais je
vous hais c'est très intéressant parce
que ça dénote aussi d'une méconnaissance
de l'histoire de l'islam d'un point de
vue historique pure et d'un point de vue
de la connaissance de la religion et moi
plus les années passent et plus je suis
atterré n'importe qui vient en n'ayant
aucune connaissance à moi ça m'arrive
souvent de poser la question demandez
bêtement la différence entre schisme et
sionisme mais même dans des des
journalistes qui qui tiennent le
crachoir et où ils ne savent pas me
donner une seule explication
exactement et je trouve ça quand on se
retrouve face à un navet un événement
qui effectivement est aussi grave que ce
qui s'est passé à partir mais même en
belgique ça a commencé au au musée du
judaïsme c'est là qu'il a lancée après
il ya eu meira et après ça ne pouvait
nous en ce moment là c'est à dire nous
les les réfugiés qui connaissions déjà
nous à ce moment là on en a senti c'est
ce que ça n'allait plus jamais s'arrêter
parce qu'on avait et parce que ces
algériens là ils sont nuls à vous nous
quand ils ont ils sont liés au moment
des années noires
nous on les a connus ils nous ont parlé
on a connu la même chose et je me suis
dit ça ça va un peu réveillé les gens
les gens vous commencé à s'y intéresser
se demander qu'est ce que c'est
l'histoire parce que résumé
l'islamisme comme étant le résultat de
la colonisation
sincèrement c'est honteux mais et c'est
extrêmement et aux centristes c'est de
décider c'est de décider qu'il est
musulman n'existait pas à mon pardon
juste une petite phrase au moment où
paris puait ça il n'est pas possible de
traverser paris en plein moyen âge
tellement l'odeur était insupportable
bagdad a construit effectivement les
premiers égouts les problèmes des
premiers bibliothèque municipale on est
au 13e siècle mais c'est pas rien non
mais je vais dire la colonisation n'a
rien à voir là imaginer que l'histoire
de l'espace arabo-musulman commence avec
la colonisation
ces nains ethnocentriste c'est là qu'est
le racisme pas lorsque nous en train de
dire battus ce qui à ce que vous
partagez ce constat finalement assez
pessimiste autour de cette table sur sur
l'esprit charlie qui peut-être un peu en
train de s'éroder parce que on ne veut
pas faire d'amalgamé ou trop critiquer
l'islam puis il ya deux choses dans le
constat là il ya ce qui est dit sur
parfois effectivement un débat qui part
en vrille parce que tout le monde se
fait spécialiste de questions complexes
méconnaît les sujets et dit un peu tout
et n'importe quoi alors on choisit ses
cibles
moi je me souviens d'une confusion qui
avait été entretenu par un propos
présidentiels à l'époque c'était nicolas
sarkozy qui était à l'elysée qui avait
parlé de france est d'apparence
musulmane donc évidemment quand on dit
ça quand on se permet en tant que
président de la république de dire une
telle ineptie derrière tout le monde
peut s'autoriser tout et n'importe quoi
et le débat devient vaseux parce qu on
mélange tout est effectivement de
musulmans passent à islamistes et
caetera et il y a quand même un fait
encore parfois racistes dans notre pays
qui tient à notre histoire coloniale et
qui fait que l'ambiguïté s'insinue un
peu partout pour autant sur l'esprit
charlie je voulais juste que de déplacer
un peu la focale là je suis plutôt
effectivement moi aussi optimiste
il ya eu charlie il ya eu le bataclan il
ya eu nice il ya eu plein de choses qui
font que
on sait que depuis cette époque là
depuis ces dernières années la menace
terroriste est très élevé elle est très
élevée et elle ne diminue pas et je me
souviens on parlait des manifestations
daloa travail à l'époque on était déjà
effectivement sous une menace terroriste
très élevé or l'état républicain sont
organisés pour garantir la pleine
sécurité des manifestations
ce n'était pas toujours réussi mais il
n'empêche que pendant plusieurs mois la
france a manifesté alors que c'était
très compliqué d'organiser la sécurité
de tout le monde aujourd'hui encore on
organise et on permet au gilet jaune de
manifester alors même que la menace
terroriste est très élevé et de ce point
de vue là on a plutôt tenu bon en termes
de cohésion nationale en termes de
cohésion sociale en termes d'esprit
apaisé et j'ajoute juste un point je
suis pas obsédé par les gilet jaune mais
dans ce que disent les gilet jaune il ya
parfois des choses un peu choquant pour
certaines personnes aient encore
remettre en cause la peine de mort moi
ça me choque en tant que citoyen mais je
trouve ça légitime si des gens ont vite
critique à la peine de mort grand bien
leur fasse c'est du débat démocratique
je trouve qu'il ya assez peu de roland
douteux concernant les questions d'islam
les questions de terrorisme etc
le café du commerce de migration à
quelques exactement le café du commerce
à quelques limites mais juste deux
points pour aller dans votre sens
lorsqu'ils ont les islamistes ont
attaqué à saint-etienne du rouvray et
ont décapité
le prêtre le père hamel on aurait pu
croire ou voir d'un coup une levée du
bouclier et qui a pas eu ou des
exactions ou ou des pogroms on aurait on
aurait pu voir ça on la pas fine dont on
a on a une société qui est quand même
intelligente qui a bien compris qu'il y
avait cette menace terroriste et
islamistes qui est importante mais
deuxième point je voudrais préciser
c'est que là il va falloir vraiment que
les démocrates que nous sommes et les
républicains nous sommes défendions la
loi sur la laïcité parce qu'on ne peut
pas accepter moi c'est vraiment pas
quatre ans après charlie de savoir que
le président de la république veut
revenir sur la loi sur la laïcité pour
donner plus de possibilités finalement à
l'islam d'être soi disant intégrés à la
société et que ce culte soit plus
reconnue c'est non c'est non parce que
la france à cette loi sur la laïcité
c'est au culte de s'attaquer exactement
de se développer elle est faite pour ça
voilà c'est comme ça c'est le dinar en
est exactement là on n'a pas à changer
et vraiment il va falloir qu'on soit à
rebooter là dessus c'est pas la seconde
ça va de l'histoire qui lie le maréchal
pétain là aussi c'est un sujet sur
lequel le gouvernement est d'une très
grande prudence que sa fille on a tenté
c'est très attention sur ce sujet
absolument et l'immigration vous avez
vous tiré directement la veine en
songeant que nous en débattrons lorsque
le projet arrivera de façon un peu plus
concrète on parlera sujets moins en
moins dramatique c'est de la fiscalité
le savez que parmi les demandes d'aidés
gilet jaune
il ya l'idée d'organiser des référendums
d'initiative citoyenne et ben bruno le
maire le ministre de l'économie l'a
trouvé une idée de référendum
c'est de demander aux français s'ils
sont d'accord pour que les riches payent
en l'occurrence plus